[Música]
muy buen día para todos comenzamos este
avance informativo con una lamentable
noticia para el mundo del cine el
legendario actor británico sean connery
conocido por sus interpretaciones de
james bond entre los 60 y 80 se murió a
los 90 años de edad la noticia fue
confirmada por la familia del actor a la
bbc de londres en acción en burgo
escocia es además recordado por haber
obtenido el oscar a mejor actor de
reparto en finales de los 80s por su
papel en los intocables además dos
premios bafta y tres globos de oro a lo
largo de su carrera participó en
películas como indiana jones y la última
cruzada el nombre de la rosa' o la roca
fue nombrado caballero por la reina de
inglaterra en el año 2000 y fue
declarado como el hombre vivo más sexy
del mundo en 1989 por la revista equipo
pasamos ahora a turquía donde avanzan
las labores de búsqueda y rescate tras
el fuerte terremoto que sacudió el
viernes el mar egeo el número total de
víctimas aumentó a 27 en ese país la
ciudad más afectada s esmirna donde
varios edificios colapsaron y 25
personas perdieron la vida se reportó
también el fallecimiento de dos
adolescentes en la isla griega de samos
después de que una pared se derrumbara
sobre ellos el ministro de medioambiente
de turquía confirmó que por lo menos hay
100 personas que han sido rescatadas que
hay otras 800 heridas tres mujeres
fueron rescatadas de los escombros en un
edificio residencial después de quedar
atrapadas durante más de 10 horas
pasamos ahora eeuu donde los candidatos
son al trump y joe biden midieron
fuerzas en el medio oeste una región del
país que fue clave para dar la victoria
al ahora presidente en el año 2016
by then tiene por el momento la ventaja
según las encuestas pero los dos
aspirantes han hecho llamados a una
movilización masiva de sus votantes la
recta final de la campaña llega marcada
por un récord de nuevos casos de kobe 19
en el país en las últimas 24 horas se
reportaron 100 mil 233 nuevos contagios
entre los estados más afectados se
encuentra en michigan carolina del norte
ohio pensilvania y wisconsin
y es que la pandemia no se detiene en
europa donde varios países se enfrentan
a una segunda ola de contagios bélgica
el país más afectado del continente
reveló un nuevo plan para limitar los
contagios como una última oportunidad
antes de un confinamiento general italia
ha contabilizado 31 mil 84 nuevos
puntajes en las últimas 24 horas se
trata del recuento diario más alto en el
país desde el inicio de la pandemia
francia donde rige ya un segundo
confinamiento nacional registró más de
49 mil 200 casos mientras que el primer
ministro griego anunció el cierre de
durante un mes de restaurantes bares
gimnasios cines y museos y la medida
entra en vigor a partir del 3 de
noviembre
y la región de américa latina y el
caribe superó el umbral de los 400 mil
muertos por kobe 19 brasil es el país
más afectado con 159 mil 477 decesos
desde el inicio de la pandemia mientras
que perú superó los 900 mil casos
confirmados la región cuenta ya con más
de 11.3 millones de casos y sigue siendo
la más afectada por la pandemia
y hasta aquí entonces este avance
informativo en france 24 continua con
nosotros feliz día
cubre las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
nutrición cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se lo pierdan
[Música]
acompáñenos en reporteros en cada semana
por france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
a samuel para ti lo mataron precisamente
por todo esto
por que personificó el renacimiento de
la república cada día en cada aula en la
libertad que se transmite y que se
perpetúa en las escuelas
samuel para ti fue asesinado porque los
islamistas quieren nuestro futuro
islamista son otros sitios y ellos estoy
convencido que con héroes silenciosos
como él nunca lo tendrán en el same
[Música]
hemos dicho claramente y seguiremos
diciendo que la libertad que permite a
un dibujante hacer caricaturas no obliga
a los musulmanes de francia a amar estás
sátiras incluso pueden odiar lass pero
absolutamente nada puede justificar
matar o dañar la integridad física de un
hombre por haber caricaturizado
es muy importante venir aquí para
mostrar nuestro dolor para decir que lo
que pasó no fue el islam es el trabajo
de matones que no tienen nada que ver
con nuestra religión porque nuestro
credo nos pide que trabajemos para hacer
que la gente viva no para matarla de
trabajo por servirles a europa bien y
dan barber estas son señales de que
occidente se encamina una vez más hacia
un periodo de barbarie francia y europa
en general no merecen las políticas de
manjón y aquellos con mentalidades
similares que esparcen semillas de odio
hasta el muselín genial ofendió a todos
los musulmanes cómo se puede insultar al
profeta
esto significa que makro no ofendió a
todos los musulmanes por eso todos
debemos unirnos y boicotear sus
productos esto es lo menos que podemos
hacer
esto no tiene nada que ver con la
libertad macro un habla de libertad y no
tiene nada que ver con eso la libertad
está en lo que es justo han insultado de
una figura en el islam que es intocable
el profeta no estamos hablando de otros
humanos además la política no debería
tener nada que ver con las religiones
porque apoya a las caricaturas que
ofenden al profeta esta no debería ser
una posición para un presidente el
presidente debe exigir que no se insulte
a ninguna religión abrupta dentro y se
fútbol
y ahora los nuevos ataques de la
libertad de expresión vienen de una
parte desde la existencia de las redes
sociales que se movilizan cuando algo no
les gusta y ese no es el problema eso
también es libertad de expresión incluso
cuando no nos gusta lo que escuchamos el
problema es que utilizan amenazas
intimidaciones e incluso amenazas de
muerte lo que claramente es inadmisible
y es algo que puede crear tormentas
alrededor de un dibujante de prensa
[Música]
france24 es rigurosidad precisión y
responsabilidad somos una familia
comprometida con el periodismo y la
verdad sin distorsión de hombres rompe
tu adecuada de rumbo a diputado
británico bertrand hertz uribe del
senado que vive en países nos vemos de
vuelta la versión bus a la fonética
tiene una nueva obra estaba fuera de mí
nada me colé al mayadin o la dina al
mensaje de casi fiesta nadie más ya
tiene aquí en france 24 tenemos a varias
personas de distintos países algo que es
un reflejo de cómo es latinoamérica con
culturas muy distintas y allí es muy
bonito encontré que en el deporte todos
tenemos algo en común difamación su
ámbito y volatilidad nacionalizaciones
xx mayor altura geopolítica en europa
nos marcan la liberté égalité actualidad
[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
nos acompaña michael camilleri director
del programa de estado de derecho de
diálogo internacional y ex asesor de
gobierno de barack obama gracias por
estar en france 24 y empezamos
preguntando la américa latina está la
expectativa de los resultados de las
elecciones en eeuu que significaría en
términos migratorios la reelección de
una una reelección de trump o también el
posible triunfo de byd en el candidato
demócrata
muy buenos días y si mira frente al tema
de migración como con muchos de los
temas claramente un segundo gobierno del
presidente trans implicaría una
continuación digamos de las políticas
que hemos visto en el primer gobierno
claramente desde el día que anunció su
uso campaña para la presidencia
restringir la migración ha sido para el
presidente tanto una prioridad y hemos
visto las consecuencias consecuencias de
esto con la separación de familias y
otras y otras consecuencias similares en
el caso de joe biden claramente tienen
prioridad digamos una un tratamiento
mucho más digno de los migrantes
[Música]
a causar las deportaciones en los
primeros días de su presidencia para
realizar digamos la política y muy
importante tiene una propuesta de gastar
cuatro mil millones de dólares en
centroamérica en los cuatro años de su
gobierno tratando de atacar las raíces
la migración es decir combatir la
pobreza la corrupción la inseguridad que
obliga muchas veces a residentes
ciudadanos de guatemala de honduras el
salvador a buscar amiga en otra vida en
los eeuu bueno pero háblenos adecúe la
crisis de venezuela también de seguir el
trump en el poder se vislumbra el
bloqueo de ambos países y qué pasaría si
ganaba idem él tuvo la responsabilidad
de la política exterior con la región
cuando fue vicepresidente de barack
obama
venezuela en vista de ese tema demasiado
muy claro digamos para él
nicolás maduro es indicador es un valor
de derechos humanos y la presión
hacia el régimen de maduro en venezuela
no va a cesar en eso sí en la política
de un gobierno de bailén probablemente
va a ser más multilateral va a priorizar
acompañar la política de eeuu con
medidas parecidas de otros países de
américa latina de la unión europea para
poder así buscar una salida finalmente
democrática induce a las elecciones
libres en venezuela pero sin trabajar de
manera unilateral en lo cual no no ha
arrojado resultados en el día del
presente con el plano comercial que
pasará por ejemplo con los acuerdos
comerciales con méxico sigan a whiter
vayan a respirar él va a cumplir el
acuerdo comercial con méxico lo ha dicho
claramente en ese ese acuerdo tiene
disposiciones en materia de protección
de trabajadores y de medioambiente que
fueron insertados a solicitud de
mandados realmente por los legisladores
demócratas en el congreso y es de
esperar que en un gobierno de bailén
esas disposiciones se van a hacer
cumplir de manera rigurosa pero digamos
no hay no hay ninguna duda que en el
acuerdo con canadá y méxico seguiría en
efecto
pues agradecemos a michael kramer lawrie
director del programa de estado de
derecho del diálogo interamericano y
también ex asesor del gobierno barack
obama por estar con nosotros aquí en 5
minutos con de france 24 y usted los
invitamos a continuar con más en nuestra
página web www puntos 24 punto com
información en cuatro idiomas para
ustedes y por supuesto también datos
importantes de la coyuntura
internacional en esta sección cinco
minutos con nos vemos más adelante con
más información
[Música]
el mundo evoluciona cada vez más rápido
las noticias no esperan es por eso que
france24 siempre estará a su lado para
compartir el mundo
para ofrecer la mejor información
internacional 24 horas del día en
cualquier circunstancia
france24 en todo lugar y cada momento
con usted
liberté égalité actual y t
todas las acciones de france 24 se
movilizan para llevarle el directo la
elección presidencial estadounidense
sobre el terreno en seis de los estados
clave nuestros enviados especiales
estarán con quienes decidirán la
elección desde carolina del norte
pasando por georgia florida arizona
wisconsin hasta pensilvania france24 le
propone postales de campaña una cita
diaria con los eeuu de hoy el 3 de
noviembre estaremos en todos los
noticieros con nuestros corresponsales
para seguir las últimas horas de esta
carrera a la casa blanca la gran noche
estadounidense una transmisión en
directo minuto a minuto para seguir y
analizar el conteo siga en vivo este
histórico evento en las señales de
france 24 en francés inglés árabe y
español y en nuestros sitios web y
aplicaciones móviles
[Música]
france24 el arte en todas sus formas
liberté égalité actually t
si bien se maneja la brillo público va
muy bien
[Música]
entre otros momentos del ciclo
[Aplausos]